في واحده من اهم المعالم المعماريه التي
ترمز لمدينه مارسيليا الفرنسيه حيث تبرز
ناطحه السحاب ضخمه بثلاثه وثلاثين طابقا
يمضي سعاد نصف وقته اليومي ليدير خطوط
الشحن البحري والجوي حول 160 دوله في
العالم ضمن امبراطوريه كبرى يقودها بثقه
وجداره لم تجعله فقط مليارديرا بل وايضا
قطبا من اخطاب الشحن الدولي فما سر هذه
الثروه ولد رودلف سعاده في لبنان عام 1970
لعائله من اصول لبنانيه فوالده جاك سعاده
هاجر الى فرنسا ابان الحرب الاهليه في
لبنان ثم حصل على الجنسيه الفرنسيه
لخدمات المياه قبل ان ينضم في عام
1994 لمجموعه سي ام اي سي جي ام التي تعد
احدى اهم الشحن في العالم قبل ان يؤسس هذه
الامبراطوريه كان جاك يتولى اداره الاعمال
العائليه بعد وفاه والده التي كانت مجموعه
من المصانع في سوريا متخصصه في انتاج
التبغ وبذور القطن وزيت الزيتون والثلج
اثناء ذلك ذهب جاك الى نيويورك فشهد هناك
الحاويه التي كان الجيش الامريكي يستخدمها
خلال الحرب وفكر في نقل البضائع بين الدول
بطريقه سريعه وهو ما جعله يؤسس شركه للنقل
البحري عندما استقر مع عائلته في مارسيليا
عام
1978 بدات الشركه التي حملت اسمها انذاك
باربعه موظفين وسفينه واحده وكانت تقدم
خدمه بحريه واحده فقط بالشحن بين مارسيليا
وبيروت ثم نمت عاما بعد عام مع حلول العام
1992 تنامت لدى جاك الذي يحمل شهاده في
الاقتصاد قناعات بان الصين ستصبح قبله
للتجار فقام بتاسيس مكتب للشركه في شنغهاي
وحتى يسيطر على السوق بشكل افضل اتبع
سياسه الاستحواذ على الشركات الاصغر كشركه
ان ال وشركه سي جي ام وشركه ديلماست كما
دخل في تحالف مع ثلاث شركات شحن اخرى
ليصبح مالكا لثالث اكبر شركه شحن حاويات
في العالم مع دخول العام 2006 في عام 2009
تاثرت الشركه بالازمه الاقتصاديه ولكن جاك
كان قادرا على تخطي تلك المرحله وواصل
نجاحاته حتى باتت الشركه تدير نحو 500
واربعين سفينه وتخدم نحو 420 ميناء تجاريا
عالميا اثناء ذلك كان رودولف تحت اداره
والده يدير بنجاح خطوط شحن مختلفه قبل ان
يصبح مسؤولا عن خطوط عبر المحيط الاطلسي
وعبر المحيط الهادئ وهو ما جعل والده يثق
بقدراته فقام بتعيينه النائب للرئيس وعضوا
بمجلس اداره سي ام اي سي جي ام في عام
2010 حيث اشرف على اعاده الهيكله الماليه
للمجموعه في عام 2015 عرض رودولف
الاستحواذ الطوعي لجميع اسهم شركه
شحن مقرها سنغافوره واصبح رئيسا لمجلس
ادارتها كما نجح في انجاز اتفاقيه تشغيليه
مع شركات كوسكو شيبينج وافرغ لاين واو سي
ال في اواخر العام 2017 قام جاك بتعيين
رودولف سعاده رئيسا لمجلس الاداره خلف
الله فقام رودولف بتنفيذ استراتيجيه جديده
تضمنت التحول الرقمي وتحسين خدمات النقل
في العام التالي وبعد وفاه جاك اصبح
رودولف وريث ثروه كبيره بالتشارك مع
عائلته لكنه بقي يقود الشركه حيث قام بعده
تحسينات لاحقه كادخال خدمات النقل الجويه
واقامه شراكه استراتيجيه
بالاضافه الى اطلاق مركز للتدريب
والابتكار تخدم الشركه اليوم تحت اداره
رودولف في اكثر من 160 دوله وتبلغ
ايراداتها نحو 47 مليار دولار فيما تقدر
ثروه العائله بواحد واربعين مليارا و400
مليون دولار امريكي فيما تقدر ثروته
الشخصيه بنحو 16 مليارا وتسعمائه مليون
دولار
[موسيقى]